[Applaudissements]
j'ai beaucoup aimé l'idée de marcher à
l'envers ça fait penser à un truc très
intéressant un souvenir une phrase qui
dit prendre du recul c'est prendre de
l'avant ce parce que prendre du recul
c'est prendre de l'élan
ça m'a fait penser à ça c'est une phrase
d'un type que certains me connaissent
peut-être qu'ils chantaient dans les
années 90 qui s'appelait mc solaar et je
vais essayer humblement de faire c'est
un peu avec vous de faire un pas de côté
ou un pas en arrière je peux faire
attention avec la drisse eps je vais pas
vous parler de l'intérêt général en tout
cas je vais pas dire le mot je pense pas
avoir besoin de dire le mot de l'intérêt
général ni de vous convaincre que vu ce
que l'on vient d'entendre de charles et
delà de la part de guillaume que
l'intérêt général aujourd'hui en 2018
notamment pour des gens comme vous de
cette génération là c'est quelque chose
qui est entièrement mêlée avec vos
intérêts respectifs individuel donc je
n'ai d'abord pas là dessus
en revanche je veux commencer un envoi
comptant en vous donnant cinq idées en
tête pas s'acquitter en parlant de cinq
personnes et en vous demandant à votre
avis moi qui donnerait à poncin vous
inquiétez pas sauf si je vois des mains
se lever en vous demandant votre avis
qu'est-ce qui est quel est le point
commun de ces cinq personnes là
quel est le point commun entre un enfant
qui au bord du lac tchad à 5 ans
aujourd'hui est en train de lutter
contre le syndrome de malnutrition aiguë
sévère entre cet enfant là au bord du
lac tchad est en train sdf au coin du
boulevard saint germain et de la rue de
rennes qui habite là-bas sur ce morceau
de trottoir depuis 25 ans vous pouvez
choisir un autre coin de paris si vous
voulez et une personne âgée dépendante
homme ou femme rue saint-guillaume sous
les toits qui ne peut plus sortir de
chez elle parce qu'elle n'a pas assez de
moyens pour le faire et un ingénieur
syrien sur un radeau au milieu de la
méditerranée est le point commun entre
ces quatre personnes là et un enfant
d'une famille très aisée où vous voulez
dans le monde pourquoi pas à paris ou
ailleurs polyhandicapés
dans ses parents ne peuvent pas
s'occuper quel est le point commun entre
ces cinq profils à notre petit enfant du
lac tchad
notre sdf du coin et l'ex trois autres
de mon point de vue il ya deux éléments
à venir le premier c'est que ça peut
être où cela a pu être nous vous moi a
pu être mon père mon grand père ça doit
être moi demain donc ça ça nous concerne
ce que je vous dis là je vous parle de
personnes qui sont comme nous
potentiellement qui porte en elle une
formidable capacité de développement et
une formidable capacité de vulnérabilité
aussi d'où l'importance que l'intérêt
général soit l'intérêt de chacun aussi
et connaissances et que nous sachions
parler français et prononcer
correctement et que nous le sachions
mais surtout ces cinq personnes là elles
ont un autre point commun et c'est le le
point sur lequel je veux un peu
développé ma pensée aujourd'hui c'est
qu'elles sont aidés par une seule et
même forme d'organisation et ses
organisations la même si elles ont des
statuts juridiques différents d'un pays
à l'autre
elles ont une particularité commune ces
organisations là je les appelle les
organisations donnent profite
cela peut aller encore un peu en partie
nous y reviendrons de l'état jusqu'à la
petite association du coin au fin fond
du limousin en france ou dans le
connecticut en passant par la grande ong
internationales ou par la nouvelle
entreprise de ss ou les nouvelles formes
de mg comme comme leçon singh à ces
organisations la se sont toujours
occupés des personnes soit à la marge de
la société soit lorsqu'elles sont à la
marge de la société accepté s'il vous
plaît le lorsqu'elles sont à la marge
qui me permet de partager avec vous mon
espoir que l'on peut être un moment
vulnérables et ne pas l'avoir été avant
et ne plus l'être après et donc ces
organisations ne profitent les ong si
vous voulez pour faire court ou les
associations
appelons-les en profite vous allez voir
pourquoi eh bien elle s'occupe de ces
personnes-là de ces vulnérabilités des
marges de la société et les choses ont
beaucoup changé depuis le jour où elles
ont commencé à s'en occuper
les choses ont changé pourquoi d'une
part parce que l'état conformément à ce
qu'a dit charles tout à l'heure a de
plus en plus de mal à porter sa
contribution aux besoins de cette
vulnérabilité là et aux besoins de ces
personnes là deuxièmement parce que le
nombre et la variété des vulnérabilités
dans le monde peut uniquement en france
ac on ciblera considérablement augmenté
et que les variétés la variété des
situations s'est développé également
et puis un troisième paramètre est venu
en entrée en jeu et il est double ce
troisième paramètre c'est d'une part que
le monde que les nouvelles générations
se sont mises à considérer la prise en
charge ou l'importance de ces personnes
lorsqu'elles sont vulnérables comme
étant un élément crucial de l' équilibre
de nos sociétés
aujourd'hui un jeune étudiant ou un
étudiant
lorsque je le crois en tout cas lorsqu
ils appréhendent le monde ne la présente
plus en faisant fi des personnes qui
sont à la marge et ne la présente plus
sans se poser la question du monde
lui-même de la planète
donc le social et l'environnement sont
devenus des sujets au centre de nos
sociétés et donc comme ce mouvement a
mené la marge au centre au burkina faso
en france aux états unis au bangladesh
en chine
partout dans le monde cette marge est le
revenu au centre et bien les
organisations qui s'en occupent sont
redevenus au centre ci est aujourd'hui
nos sociétés elles ne dépendent plus du
triptyque historique état entreprise
individus citoyens elles sont et elles
doivent leur équilibre alors moins un
parent
l'alliance entre ces quatre acteurs
l'état toujours plus ou moins présent
fonction des cultures des histoires et
les pays les entreprises plus ou moins
cupides
elles ne le sont pas toutes les
individus plus ou moins égoïste plus ou
moins intéressés par l'intérêt général
et les ong le monde profite qui par
nature semble être purement destinée à
s'occuper de l'intérêt général
et c'est bien parce que ce secteur il a
des vertus d'abord je voudrais chanter
un point de vue que vous avez peut-être
j'espère que vous n'avez pas mais je
fais l'hypothèse que vous l'avez ce
point de vue c'est que le jeune profite
en tout cas en france dans sa ceinture
juridique qui est la structure
associative le monde profite ce n'est
pas ne pas faire de profit
l'association des étudiants qui
s'occupent des migrants à sciences po
la croix rouge française l'association
du club de rugby intel au fin fond du
pays basque l'unicef france
action contre la faim l'association la
fondation saint joseph qui gère un
hôpital dans le 14e arrondissement ont
le droit dû faire de profits ce sont des
structures qui sont des structures
potentiellement dans le secteur marchand
dans le secteur du profit la seule vraie
différence
la vraie interdiction qui les sépare du
monde qu'on appelle capitaliste ou du
monde du marché c'est que se profilent à
ne peut pas être destinés aux fondateurs
il ne peut être destinée que à
satisfaire écoutez ces deux mots s'il
vous plaît l'objet social de ces
organisations la gare dont le l'objet
social
je le reprendrais tout à l'heure donc
j'espère avoir cassé quelque chose c'est
que le jeune profite ce n'est pas être
loin de l'argent ce n'est pas dédaigner
la performance ce n'est pas s'interdire
de mesurer l'impact ce que l'on fait ce
n'est encore moins refuser la question
de la production de richesse ou de
valeur
le jeune profite c'est ne pas rémunérer
le capital par l'exploitation des
valeurs que l'on produit pourquoi je
parle très fort en vous disant ça parce
que je pense que c'est au coeur de ce
qui est en train de se passer ou en tout
cas pour moi de ce qui doit se passer
qu'est-ce qu'il doit se passer et
charles l'a dit et guillaume aussi l'a
dit et d'autres le disent il doit se
passer un moment où ces structures
quelles que soient leurs différences et
leur variété quelle que soit la nature
des actions qu'elle mène se met à
l'intérieur de ce qui est la règle
commune de la vie sur terre
une des règles communes de la vie sur
terre qu'elle nous plaise ou non cet
espace l'asse l'espace deûle échanges
c'est l'espace du marché et ce n'est pas
une posture politique libérale plutôt
que socialiste que je dis là c'est une
constat nous participons tous à les
changes
la question c'est quelles sont les
termes de l'échangé mais bref ces
structures ne sont pas dans cet espace
là aujourd'hui
elles ont fait un chemin pour revenir au
centre comme je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure
il leur reste un chemin à faire pour
arriver dans ce territoire là pourquoi
parce que c'est le territoire où l'on
sait mesurer la valeur des choses et
peut-être que les crypto currency
changeons ça demain mais aujourd'hui
et moi mon horizon et je m'en excuse
s'ils veulent le votre est beaucoup plus
large
mais le mien ne m'amène pas à me sentir
capable d'inventer autre chose que
l'argent
donc je fais avec accordez moi ça s'il
vous plaît tant qu'il y à ça et le
marché l'enjeu de mon point de vue c'est
que ces organisations ne profite qu ils
ne le sont pas vous l'avez bien vu
puis se mettre à bénéficier de ce qui
est le plus puissant aujourd'hui mais
pas pour produire les désagréments
pauli 2-2 la folie de ce système
beaucoup trop financier rémunérant
beaucoup plus le capital que le
bien-être
pour au contraire apporté deux choses à
porter cette formidable capacité de
création de valeurs humaines que porte
la formidable variété des organisations
ne profite constatez avec moi s'il vous
plaît que cette variété de valeurs
humaines elle est tous azimuts
c'est bon pour les gens qui sont
accompagnés et d'ailleurs au surpluss
vous savez bien que de plus en plus
notamment les ong internationales ne
sont plus empreint de faire du top down
avec les enfants du bord du lac tchad
mais plutôt en train de définir ensemble
avec les communautés mais aussi en
france et ailleurs
quels sont leurs besoins et les
solutions à mettre en place donc les
personnes avec lesquelles nous
travaillons et qui ont des besoins
profite de cette vertu des ong
mais les personnes qui travaillent
salariés comme moi ou comme d'autres
parmi vous profite aussi de cela je
profite humainement parlant je gagne ma
vie en tout cas moins bien que si
j'étais dans un grand groupe commercial
mais je profite de cela et les bénévoles
qu'ils soient administrateurs qu'ils
soient acteurs sur le terrain profite
aussi de cela profite au sens où nous
l'avons vu tout à l'heure
cette activité-là cet engagement là nous
porte nous nourrit nous rappelle que
nous sommes autre chose que un
équivalent financiers nous rappelle que
nos vies ont du sens ça c'est la
première vertu de ces organisations là
et elle est allée pas cardinal elle et
tous azimuts et puis la deuxième vertu
c'est que je pense que ces organisations
là sont un garde-fou face à la folie
financière
à partir du moment où l'on accepte d'une
part de transformer la valeur humaine en
ce qui encore aujourd'hui le meilleur
moyen d'évaluer cela c'est à dire
l'argent les éléments qui constituent
les termes de l échange mais non pas
pour rémunérer de la finance ou du
capital
mais pour améliorer encore les process à
l'oeuvre et c'est ça le modèle en
profite et bien à partir du moment où on
accepte cette idée là
on peut rêver un petit peu à ce à quoi
pourrait ressembler un monde où cette
approche à la fois libre fondée sur
chacun d'entre vous je m'inscris
pleinement dans ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure concernant la transformation
profonde digital qui n'est pas en
surface mais qui est en profondeur et
donc sur la capacitation empowerment de
chacun d'entre nous nous avons ça et
donc si ça se réalise cette forme qui
est la forme la plus libre de
l'engagement des hommes avec un grand h
et des femmes entre eux et bien pourra
je l'espère conduire l'enfant du petit
enfant est aujourd'hui au bord du lac
tchad et qui ne sait pas se nourrir et
bien conduire l'enfant de cet enfant
devenu adulte à ne pas avoir besoin de
nous à ses côtés je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]